guys this week we got a trailer for M
night Shyamalan glass it's the sequel to
unbreakable and split and we saw the
first trailer at comic-con I did it
break down a bit go check that out here
I thought we'd do just a quick it a
little baby boy doubt of the new details
like a trailer that's right we got
another baby breakdown right yeah
customary spoiler warning in case we get
too good at predicting stuff some people
were saying like this trailer predicted
too much but all trailers predict stuff
so that's an invalid complaint actual
pieces of a movie here we go well first
let's I got Bruce Willis's character
this is David Dunn he has the powers of
super tiller durability and strength he
can benchpress paint cans along with the
ability to touch people's hands and you
can see the bad things they've done
bench press paint cans the poster
actually revealed this hero's name as
the overseer and I love that name
because I just think this passive hero
was like eating a big sandwich watching
his friends moving firm I'm overseeing
now we do get a subtle nod to this power
when he had when David asked dr. le
staple in the trailer that Sarah
Paulsen's character so you're not gonna
shake my hand and let me walk out of
here and then the you know she's got a
point like yeah ha nice try he wants to
shake her hand to see what horrible
stuff she did which I'm kind of curious
would horrible stuff she did because
there is a theory that dr. staple may
have powers herself maybe like telepathy
love that could be how she was able to
find and imprison all these
super-powered individuals and keep them
in check and she knows what their
vulnerabilities are we also learned how
dr. staple controls Kevin krumitz James
McAvoy's character he has 24 split
personalities including the super-strong
beast flash bulbs that switch his
personalities they flash and they
flashed kind of like an old-school TV
remote that only goes up or down in one
direction like nope we got a cycle
through so you know and then you can
actually see these flash bulbs in his
room but you can also see them behind
dr. staple in the community room so like
you can kind of see him she brings them
everywhere she goes to control him and
keep him but also to try to like trigger
and see which like she can read his mind
to be like oh I'm not talking to the
right personality right now
I think most interestingly we learn more
about Elijah prices motive in this movie
this is same oil Jackson is mr. glass
he's a Biddle broan comic book obsessed
criminal mastermind we hear his
voiceover telling Kevin I need your
abilities to get all out of here to show
the world we exist and he tells David I
found someone who require your full
potential you shouldn't hide in the
shadows so you kind of see what his plan
is here it sounds like he's kind of got
this magneto from x-men personnel maybe
even kill monger like if our advancement
makes us superior why should we hide and
if you remember in unbreakable mr. glass
orchestrated several terrorists
disasters who's hoping to find a hero
and like bring him out of shadows it
sounds like he's continuing with that
plan with the beast like unleashing a
super villain on the world and I think
this is one of the few times you see a
villains real motive already in the
trailer like I know what his goal is and
I think it's an interesting goal but I
also just like the way that this movie
appears to be embracing and mr. glasses
mania for comic-book tropes like it's
almost like a meta deconstruction of the
of these whole idea he's got that mg mr.
glass sigil one is it looks like an
ascot or collar or whatever that is I
thought it was a necklace but it's just
like on it and if you look at a color
palette of these trailers and footage is
amazing so there's like a purple versus
green color palette with purple being
the color of mr. glass and green being
the color of David Dunn it was there and
very muted terms and you can see
throughout the trailer there's like
imagery that's like oh if it's green
here this is like a heroic moment if
it's purple this is a villainous moment
and you see that with a slow-motion shot
in the trailer of David unfurling is
green raincoat and it kind of looks like
a superhero cape the way it works I like
there was a one thing.you moat you
mentioned in in Kevin's cell you have
the lights in David's cell there's
sprinklers all over because water is his
vulnerabilities the way she's setting
all this up it doesn't seem like she's a
great individual thinking she's like
maybe like Nurse Ratched
yeah brings up the worse than everyone
and torture them and she's she's putting
these people have powers and she's in
power over them as long as they stay
there well let us know what you think
about this trailer in the comments below
and yeah once it can go check out our
the trailer breakdown we did from the
one from Comic Con there's a lot of
interesting details going on and this
movie comes out January 18th and it's
something that the night of the two
previous films had was straight up
antagonist action on super-powered
levels and this seem like there's a lot
of fight scenes like shared up I'm just
curious how he's gonna direct those yeah
let's go slow thanks for watching